Alam County DA Pamela Price's work
laptop stolen from SUV in Oakland the
sources say that's right the da in uh in
the B one of the Das in the Bay Area who
uh apparently softon crime is now the
victim of softon crime policies this
isn't the first one I I just I just St
last week about the New Orleans Soros
spack da who was carjacked I think with
his mom good yeah well I mean it's not
good it needs to happen yes but but they
want it to happen yeah well then good
that it happens to them because they
need to learn they need to I have no
mercy on these people I I see what
you're saying right and we laugh because
of Shad FR but the problem is the Alam
County DA is probably laughing with you
do you think yeah absolutely they
intentionally do this and what happens
to them they go it worked we did it we
won we have destroyed the city yay and
then what happens is conservatives are
like haha great we agree and they're
like these idiots are agreeing with us
these people are destroying our once
great cities and conservatives are
laughing along with them what are we
going to do about them though that's the
thing V yeah nothing unless the
populations decide that they want to
vote these people out this is going to
continue to happen and it's it's been
going on for the better part of 10 years
it didn't just it happened overnight
these these Das and stuff they've
they've won multiple they've got their
their administrations well entrenched
into the the local areas and until the
population decides I'm tired of it that
that it's not going to change and not
for nothing but your average person that
has kids and a job that doesn't pay
attention to politics all the time they
don't really pay much attention they
don't know what's going on they're not
aware and when you tell them i' I've had
the experience myself I'll tell my
friends that are left leaning I was just
in California a couple weeks ago I'll
tell my friends that are left leaning
about things and they just don't believe
it they're astounded they have no idea
and I don't blame them because they look
you got a family that's the most
important thing in your life you got
kids that's the most important thing in
your life I get it but you do have to be
aware of what is going on in your own
municipality we've got a guy in Philly
named Larry crer he's a disaster nobody
even knows his name they don't even know
his name this guy has turned the city
into a complete disaster not that we
were ever great it's been a disaster
since I've been born but right now what
we have you can't even go downtown
anymore and this what was this woman
doing with a laptop in her car visible
by the way how stupid this is how stupid
these people are well who knows I it's
it's it's it probably was not visible
who knows uh because they smash out so
what people are doing now in the Bay
Area is they're leaving their their the
the the back Gates of their Vans and
SUVs open and they're they're leaving
the doors open yeah I why so that
criminals won't smash out the windows to
come and so if the doors right so they
walk up to they walk up to any car with
nothing in it and they'll smash the
windows out and then check the trunk and
then leave that's why we got the Second
Amendment we and we seeing this taking
place throughout the United States and
all of these Democratic run down
districts people when you keep voting
for the same people and you are
expecting a different outcome it's not
going to happen that's the internet
definition of insanity but like like
like Phil Phil Phil mentioned these
people don't know and uh you know I can
say proudly that uh the past few holiday
Cycles I've encountered many people who
engage exactly as as Phil said you'll
say something like yes X happened and
they'll go that's not true there's no
way and then uh this is two years ago
then last year they're like you know I
read that and then I was reading this
thing too and it's like people are
starting to realize Ian was mentioning
this a couple weeks ago that whenever a
crazy story comes out he immediately has
to call his mom to make sure he gets the
information to her before the mainstream
media can put some cover up over it he
is his own breaking news to his mom yeah
mom you're going to hear the story
here's the link it's from this article
they're going to come out and they're
going to say something and then he's
like if I don't if I don't tell her
she'll believe some crazy nonsense later
mother watches that stuff and the things
that she believe she's probably watching
this but she's never watched the podcast
before I know that much but you know the
things that you believe if you only get
your news from the mainstream media it's
unbelievably sad how misinformed these
people are and willingly willingly it's
all out there we know it we found out to
some degree to some extent I agree with
you there I'm I harp on uh Barack Obama
in the 2012 I think it was ndaa that
repealed the smithm uh or that had the
smithm modernization ACT essentially
what it what it said is that for since
the 40s the federal government wasn't
allowed to propagandize the American
people essentially they couldn't produce
materials for dissemination inside the
United States and in 200 I think it was
12 um the smithm modernization Act was
part of the ndaa that Barack Obama
signed and it happened just at the time
that the
smartphone was coming into it was
getting into everyone's pocket and
social media with the like button was
essentially the most powerful uh mind
control tool ever invented and so you've
got people that have that are in in uh
in the tech industry and stuff like that
are producing these applications
that draw people in and people love to
use them and the federal government is
given free reign to feed these Tech
Industries tech companies and whatever
information they want and the media and
the tech companies do it willingly there
was no need for payoff or anything
because what they what the federal
government offered was access if you do
these things you scratch my back I'll
scratch yours and that was the beginning
of the the uh the tech companies in my
opinion becoming a part of the military
IND industrial comp and you never hear
the Republicans who are supposed to be
on our side about the propaganda stff
you never hear them talk about that act
and you never will there's there's one
candidate in Texas Caroline Kane only
person I've ever heard bring it up I'm
pretty sure that there's a guy running
that will talk about it uh the AKA guy
Bron I forget Bron's last name uh but uh
but he'll talk about it he mentioned it
um but it's something that people need
to know the fact that the federal
government is not only allowed to
disseminate IM information into into the
popul
but is doing it in conjunction with tech
companies that have the ability to
literally control people's opinions
right people will behave in remarkably
different ways if they get likes or they
get you know approval from their friends
and that's exactly what the like button
does it gives people that little
dopamine hit and those
small those kind of small dopamine hits
that are not something that that is a
big deal it's a little bit all the time
it It Go flies under the radar and it
has had a massive massive impact on the
population people talk about how in like
2012 13 everything seems so much crazier
now than before that and and you hear
that people my age talking about that
all the time you know and I truly
believe that it is because prior to 2012
2011 you didn't have the kind of
consistent propagandizing from the
federal government I don't I don't think
so I think you said to yourself with the
with the algorith algorithms private
sector that's not that was before uh uh
the the the repealing of this act and
the US government has been
propagandizing for a long time a lot of
the stuff that we see leaked from
Wikileaks for instance and from other
hacker groups around that time showed
they were doing this well before and I
think what what they ultimately did with
this was more overt it was The Simpsons
esque super Lial where they just launch
these american-backed foreign uh uh uh
SP like media companies I don't think
that repealing this propaganda Act is
what made everything crazy I think it's
social media and the internet and that's
why the '90s was the last decade right
like every every decade is is easily
discernible except for the 2000s and
Beyond it's a big mess yeah and it's
because the internet fractured Global
culture American culture and it's
continued to I think it's going to be
rebuilding itself though I think uh it
it shatters into all these different
Pockets where people start listening to
very specific things specific people and
you no longer have uh I said I said this
10 years ago I was at a conference I
said Fame is done because of the
internet and I was like you're going to
have famous people but it's not going to
be like you know actually fil I were
talking about this like Metallica the
biggest band ever yeah but it's because
there there was a period where culture
was more unified yes and there were
fewer channels to get access to music
Metallica being the best got everybody
but now there's probably a band very
very very good very great music but they
have a much harder time reaching as many
people because no longer straight top
toown broadcast tower it's more even out
everything is Niche now but I'm I'm I'm
kind of thinking that things will start
to rec coales again they'll start to
come back together for a combination of
reasons one people are like power
naturally does this and so we're seeing
people want to be like each other so
there's Trends and they want to follow
these Trends but more importantly the
powers that be are desperately trying to
Cobble back together the broadcast tower
so they can have singular control over
what people
think yeah and we see that a lot you
know some like the elderly population
they stay home all day they watch the
news channels all day and they believe
everything that's being shown on the
news you know they don't search for any
type of education to dispel anything
that they're seeing on the TV so that's
why it's so important that you talk to
them you know help people understand
that everything that you see on the
media isn't necessarily true cuz the
timly in particular were raised in a
different era of information right I me
when you only had the radio had like
four channels it's very different not
that you necessar should have believed
everything lie could lie way better then
but also there was very few Outlets to
challenge it and now we have a lot of
ways to challenge information in fact it
can happen so rapidly it's often hard to
keep up with and I think that's where uh
people who are not as engaged either
because of their age or because of their
lifestyle sort of get lost they can only
get the headlines and that's not enough
I've talked about my uh my show idea a
couple times here which which is more
like like a half-ass show idea cuz it's
like never going to get made but the
idea being that in the future I'll give
you the very quick version the planet
basically is post-apocalyptic there's
one city left it's the last City it's
relatively big and no one has any idea
what happened to humanity or how
civilization collapsed long story short
it turns out all of humanity still
exists they just are in underground
bunkers in the metaverse plugged in
plugged their brains into the neuralink
and the reason why the last City doesn't
know this is because they they consume
information in a dramatically different
way the idea for that is basic basically
because it's happening now older people
don't know how to use I'm not saying
they absolutely don't I'm saying most
old people don't use Twitter don't use
Tik Tok or Instagram and get their
information only from the authority
figures on TV so they are living in
Bubble World and when you go to them and
you're like hey here's a thing that's
true what you're believing is fake
they're like I don't know what you're
talking about you're like let me show
you the tweet I don't know what that is
you may as well be going to someone and
being like you don't know what's going
on with Joe Biden because you're not in
the un plugged into the neuralink and
getting the information down oh there it
is new information proving his
corruption and then they're like what
information yeah he took $200,000 how do
you know that it was wired right to my
brain if you were plugged in you'd know
it too I don't know how to plug into
that stuff I'm going to turn on CNN CNN
doesn't talk about it that's basically
the gist of the the story I was making
up is basically see that what we're
seeing now with how people consume
information you can go to your friends
and family and there's a reason why your
older relatives and family holidays
don't know these things and don't
believe you because they're not plugged
in the same way all of you are I mean if
you're watching this show you are
plugged
in yeah you're you're engaged in a
different way and I think that's one of
the interesting things that we'll see
happen with definitely Millennials
probably gen Z is that they are ra I
mean I know more and more people and I
wish I had the data with me on me to
Bear to to to prove this but one of the
biggest changes culturally is uh that
people don't have cable anymore there
are tons of families that just don't
have it you know college students who
are getting their first apartments or
young adults whatever they don't get
cable because they only need Wi-Fi
because they stream everything anyways
uh there is a complete disconnection
from an entity that used to have access
people maybe that's good on the other
hand they are relyant on a very
decentralized way of getting information
and that could also be bad I mean this
is why well kind of I mean it's it's
centralized too that it's on Tik Tok
it's on the on same platform it's no
longer the internet anymore like our
millennial generation GL up with the
internet and going to different sites
and stuff now it's on platforms these
platforms have organizations Behind
These Pages yeah so another
centralization of news source which then
unfortunately leaves it really
vulnerable to this sort of like top down
control media narrative saying like it's
going to be one way or the other and
this is the only way to hear the story
so big big agendas thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 pm and become a member
over at timcast.net